[Music]
in blurred lines do submitted by don't
gamble a professor of psychology
discusses whether or not you should try
to be friends with your boss
no where's this about gambling or is
this about friendship the person
submitting person was just putting a
personal [ __ ] let's mobilize about
gambling stupid by it don't gamble
doesn't work [ __ ] work I always have
gambling do a reasonable you basically
have to avoid Vegas altogether you can't
ask that
you can't even line up the airport yeah
literally
okay anyway so this piece here is just
exploring the idea of like people
becoming friends with their bosses so
I'm learning the lines getting a little
comfortable and so there was this 2018
survey that and so reached researchers
surveyed 3,000 people with full-time
jobs across 21 industries and they found
that the area between a strictly
business relationship and a friendship
was well populated so nearly seventy
percent of employees surveyed had their
bosses personal phone numbers a quarter
had spent social time with them and
visited their home and sixty percent had
met their bosses significant other
mmm-hmm cuz they had to they went to
their house your boss has Horford in any
like no and it's kind of like yeah [ __ ]
it's kind of weird at work yeah you
wouldn't say nice actually what do we
keep asking though you have to like
that's what Michael Scott how do you do
that look at Pam and Jim they had to go
and then they had to be subjected handle
drama didn't believe you I believe you
my mom worked that like one of these
tempo like fortune 500 companies and her
she never had dinner with their boss I
just remember her and her friends were
just like talk [ __ ] about the point is
fortune 500 meet just like those big
publicly traded company Fortune magazine
names you
500 company burners like AT&T or like
these big companies my mom was actual of
like 501 the custom greatness
yeah II never uh I don't remember them
ever hanging out with like the
higher-ups
I guess well maybe they asked her a
bunch and she's like maybe they never
asked her that sounds like the most
realistic no your mom she's kind of a no
no definitely not dinner tonight I'll
tell you that
yeah so then 30% of people surveyed said
that their boss had asked them for
advice about a personal issue whoa is
this a rash so for a lot of managers or
bosses or people that are like not at
the same level as you in your profession
they if they have their favorites they
tend to go like the overcorrect against
their bias towards them in order to seem
impartial so it actually kind of hurts
your career a bit and I actually
experienced or I witnessed this and an
experienced it but I witness it at my
old job at the hospital because one of
my co-workers was literally like best
friends with our boss and anytime there
was like something like an extra thing
to be given like an extra task or
whatever that you would want to take up
or whatever she would never look at that
chick because she's like I never want to
make it seem like I'm keeping all that
conflict of interest so she would like
overdo it to the point where like this
chick would never get it opportunity
yeah because they're trying to appear
neutral but it just ends I mean they're
also very aware of the fact that the
rest of the team knows that they have a
very close relationship so then they're
trying to be like oh I'm not trying to
like give you an extra special moment
but then it ends up working against dude
I heard that I saw something that Joe
Rogan got his black belt later than he
would have because in an eddy Bravo so
tight that any Bravo like waited long
for that reason that you're talking
about because everyone knows that their
type submit' him worth extra heart yeah
just kind of [ __ ] the sucks
cool he definitely deserves it now he's
got a story yeah I think it was like
eight years because to this brown gone
is black thought how long as I usually
take eight years for the whole thing
like eight to ten for the whole thing
but you got eight years from just brown
the blouse I stopped that brown bill I
swear to God I did you start with white
you still you start with white you go to
yellow you go to green go to orange go
to Bosh yes you got a pink then it's
turquoise no I just I just said I was
like I just thought it would like just
karate yeah we had to do caught us and
everything I took karate literally for
like seven give me something second I
went through this before okay when we
count it with this info it was a Chinese
was it's Nissan see it's Japanese
oh well yeah and it was a Japanese what
the [ __ ] do you want from me this one is
a real story I believe I controlled you
this much I can't believe I had to do
this much this is why I don't tell
people the truth because and I open up
they always think a line and they know
that's not how it works it's because you
lie a lot that me people so we never not
always have shift the earth I have the
same problem of these people that I'm
telling that these people whoa bro are
these people now no it's me and here me
and him people what sitting in that seat
tell you a story you guys [ __ ]
picking me apart when I earn this seat
yeah thank you very much for you said
I'll believe
[Laughter]
alright hey what's really good at it and
I was gonna be a ninja then what they
promise you on the way in no I just
thought I was like well there's I ain't
no black ninjas yes we talking about
May one black ninja to Wesley Snipes is
a [ __ ] black ninja you see bladed
laser beam
yeah man Michael J watch my weight for
sure but we name - what's your point
Michael Jai White was a spawn he was our
son
oh my god Amy like you've seen it
straight to VHS Marshall okay anyway
that's cool yeah
wait why are we talking about belt
anyway you're welcome yeah the thing
going back to the article boom yeah
Julian oh boy I know the last one I was
[ __ ] lost back baby
yeah so what are your guys experiences
with bosses and friendships it's like a
healthy medium I feel like because it my
other job to like I feel like I got
pretty like friendly with my managers
and stuff but like at the same time it
was like if they had to make a business
call or whatever I just be like okay
that's like the business things have to
like you go to their house to meet their
spouses I've been invited to my current
managers house but I just have a gun
it's like really far solar in Santa
Clarita and I gotta have all the way up
there it was an aside like gotta - I
guess like entertainment in working with
people you know how to like the the
traditional work force that I'll I got
cool pauses because I you know the
teacher like like some of the people go
out and I never really hang with people
like that so like who I guess I consider
my boss at ATD was like the first boss
that I really like hungry like that
everybody else a chance for me yeah I
never really wanted to hang out with any
of them either so let's say psych trying
to smash and give me some money there
you go I've never had that maybe I only
had two jobs before this job oh wow way
to sweep off a fee board
my old man was my boss it was that good
well no it you know sometimes you're
like okay I have to do school project I
can't come in like that kind of [ __ ]
what are you doing I was like doing
janitor [ __ ] around
around the office oh yeah and then but
but then it
he definitely um was harder I think on
me then I think he was another I would
for sure if I had it my own kid working
for me for sure I'd make it work I think
it was great I think it's great yeah I
think it's good too I like that I tried
to do the same thing in my daughter like
I make her do my inventory she's in
charge my inventory updated my website
and all that type of stuff and I'm like
really hard on her not just like cuz
she's my daughter because like I don't
want her to think that the world is
gonna be nice cuz she's cute she's tall
although I'd be like really hard I was
like she messed up one order or
something like that so I like I just
grabbed the computer just slapped it
with it because I like you got to learn
right
sometimes people get some bad they hit
you then what you gonna do roundabouts
when they hit you she just [ __ ]
failed to the grant and that was another
thing like that was made of main
my daughter has taken karate my daughter
took karate for about five years right
still she did block it no took the
laptop to the ti that is a waste of
money right and of waste of left which
is fine to the ground if you rip out the
carpet she hits the concrete yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what did you say I speak I speak Chinese
and then he's like guy said I don't
think you're you're a Bravo and then
you're like hold on I have a [ __ ]
hernia home
that was actually reaching for my gun
what did you say the B by 2 here fights
neighborhood we got I don't know like
for me with relationships and bosses I
mean before working here I I didn't
really talk to my bosses like super
super tight like I I would never go
outside of the workplace it was always
like a cool relationship but what did
you do at the hospital I was a surgical
surgical tech surgical no sterile
processing technician did you still a
lot from the hospital never worked at a
job wagon steal something from them like
take from car man I took things they
have a lot of these reusable bags like
I'm getting people like there to take
this stuff out of the whole car and
lecture loan it to us just take those
just all the time because I would always
forget back so when I go to write never
stole [ __ ] oh really wow I'm glad you
didn't because you works at a bank
deposit envelopes
are like I worked at a juice bar and we
may have coffee and [ __ ] I would still
pay for my [ __ ]
oh man honest journeys oh my god I was
putting shoes and journeys boxes taking
them out to the dumpster like I can't
everything my counsel I was just taking
cases of meat just putting them up wrong
just a raw meat man just terrible this
is melts it by the time I get home I
just make one big ball hamburgers see
those pirate this is why you didn't want
to hang out your bosses cuz you don't
want to invite them over and then really
all of like I don't know
and then mr. Carmack's is like
listen I can't feed you today there's
somebody stealing plastic bags
we're losing my ass I'm losing my
[ __ ] ass
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]